Life is an unusual and mysterious phenomenon.
It is thought that there are great many places in the universe with minimal
conditions necessary for life to originate and evolve.
However, as we all know,
no direct and irrefutable proof of their being biological life or swear has been
found apart from our own planet search for extraterrestrial
life forms is high on the list of priorities and space exploration.
And its object is to give an answer to the question that has been exciting.
The human mind,
since times immemorial are we alone in the universe are all.
For biological life to originate and start evolving.
A medley of a great number of factors is called for the chief ones are liquid
water and energy source and certain chemical diversity.
Apart from the earth,
several more places in the solar system are potential life harboring candidates
with Mars as the most prospective one,
and most closely studied starting from the recent past.
Still there are chances of discovering AI and life beyond its Orbi. Two,
all it takes is to have a closer look at the next closest planet to our so Mars,
if we'll look away from the sun,
Jupiter is the largest planet in the solar system.
Its mass is 318 times out of the earth.
This is a gas giant made up mostly of hydrogen and helium.
Apart from these methane ammonia,
sulfur and nitrogen compounds and water rice have been detected in its
atmosphere.
In spite of the diversity of chemical compounds,
the possibility of finding life forms on Jupiter itself is minuscule.
What will the absence of any hard surface high temperature years of the planets
inner layers and unimaginable pressure in its interior,
biological creatures simply have no chances of survival
at the same time.
Jupiter boasts quite a vast array of moons.
Four of the most well-known ones, IO,
Calisto Ghanim and Europa were discovered as far back as in
1609 by Galileo Galilee,
quite close to the moon and mercury in size there on the list of the largest
satellites in the solar system.
It has also suggested that Jupiter accumulated substantial amounts of thermal
energy due to gravitational contraction. When forming as there is,
it is now giving off more of this energy than it is getting from the sun.
That is why the gas giant with all the objects orbiting.
It may be seen as a curious version of the solar system in miniature.
At first glance,
Jupiter moons may appear to have no prospects in terms of searching for
extraterrestrial life far from the sun.
They're encased in ice and their atmospheres are not dense.
However, on closest scrutiny,
these celestial objects reveal something excitingly
Calisto,
Europa and ADE are highly likely to have liquid oceans onto the ice shell
estimates show that space objects with concealed oceans may offer favorable
conditions for life, even if they're much further from their star than planets.
Like our earth are from the sun.
The thick IC shell on their surface serves not only as protection against
radiation and media writing for, but also acts as fairly good thermal isolation.
That is why it is feasible.
That conditions inside a massive layer of water may be good enough for life to
originate and evolve there.
These assumption as make Jupiter satellites,
some of the most attractive objects for exploration within the solar system.
And now let's have a closer look at each of
ADE is the largest and most massive celestial object in Jupiter and virus of
all the satellites and the solar system.
It is not the one sporting the most impressive dimensions,
but it also resembles a real planet more than any other Ghanim MES
radius measures, 2,634 kilometers,
which is 8% more than that of mercury as for its mass,
it equals 1.48 times 10 to the,
a power of 23 kilograms.
This is twice the massive arm moon.
Interestingly ADE is the only satellite in our solar system with a liquid metal
core and its own magnetosphere
processes of nuclear decay take place in ADE's interior.
This heats the site still more with the average surface temperature,
110 Kelvin or 163 degrees CELs below zero.
The core on the other hand is estimated to be as hot as up to 1,500,
700 Kelvin investigations of ADE's magnetic field
carried out by the Galileo probe showed that there may be a multilayer salty
ocean under the satellite's icy shell as deep down as 200 kilometers
or more.
The number of layers may reach for water in each is of different salinity
density and temperature with a layers separated from each other,
by some ice spectra graphic investigations of Ghanim surface.
Show it to have a rather rare refined oxygen atmosphere. This however,
isn't a irrefutable proof of their being biological life on the satellite
molecular oxygen is likely to form as a result of the exposure of water rice to
ultraviolet radiation, hydrogen.
The other product of this chemical reaction floats away into space oxygen,
meanwhile,
which is a heavier element settles close to the surface apart from large
amounts of water rice,
other elements found on ADE surface than dioxide, sulfur,
dioxide, sulfates, and some other organic substances.
They may well have originated in the depths of the subsurface ocean,
but the mechanisms of their settling on the satellite surface are still not
clear.
Calisto is another celestial object, potentially just as a for life.
This satellite is Jupiter's second largest one and lies furthest from it.
Its diameter measures 4,820 kilometers almost
like that of mercury Calisto is encased in an icy shell as thickers
80 to 150 kilometers.
And it highly likely that there is a salty ocean concealed under it containing
large amounts of ammonia and other substances.
The estimates of its depth range from 50 to 300 kilometers at its
temperature is around 251 Kel or 21 degrees.
CELs below zero.
According to models due to impurities and high pressure,
the water in the ocean should remain in its liquid state below the
subsurface ocean.
There is bound to be a layer of ice as stickers around 300 kilometers and
the satellite core made up of water ice and rocks lies still deeper down
Calisto surface is P marked with craters spectral analysis of light
reflected from this celestial object revealed not only water vapor and Silicon
rocks, but also ammonia carbon dioxide,
sulfur iron and magnesium compounds as well as Sterlings complex,
organic polymers containing the hydrogen,
these brightly colored substances form on the surfaces of celestial bodies.
A result produced by ultraviolet radiation.
Calisto happens to lie too far from Jupiter to get more heat from it.
Besides the ti influence exerted by the giant neighbor,
isn't enough to de form the satellite,
although friction and in the process would heat it up.
Also most of this bodies made up of ice,
whereas it is preferable that there should be solid drugs,
which will saturate water with elements vital for lifeforms to originate
with the diversity of chemical compounds here,
rather modest and the temperature quite low.
It hardly imp roof's chances of life evolving here. Still.
This possibility should of course not be ruled out yet.
The most promising of Jupiter satellites in terms of searching for alien life is
Europa. The smallest of Jupiter four Galilean moons.
It is just a bit smaller than our moon.
The equatorial temperature on this celestial body is 110 Calvin or
163 degrees Celsius below zero at the poles.
Temperatures may drop to 50 Calvin or
223 degrees Celsius below zero
Europa is tightly locked to Jupiter facing it with the same side,
only however its rotation isn't synchronized.
Ideally there are deviations from the calculated trajectory.
This may may that there is a liquid layer between Europa surface.
And this assumption is confirmed by observation of interaction between
the satellite and Jupiter's magnetic field carried out by the Galileo space
probe in the late 20th century.
Apart from that analysis of crevices,
Europa surface is covered with shows that the satellites crust moved 80 degrees
with respect to the I.
This would've been impossible without a liquid layer between them.
The massive neighbor exerts a strong influence over Europa by causing powerful
tidal waves in its subsurface ocean. This way,
the satellite is heated still more by internal friction estimates show
that the temperature and Euro is interior is high for a notion of water to be in
liquid state.
Its depth may reach a hundred kilometers and its volume may be twice that of
the global ocean on our earth.
Europa is covered with an even layer of exceptionally smooth and clear ice.
The highest elements of relief tower,
just several hundred meters above the surface.
The thickness of the icy crust may be anything from 10 to 30 kilometers.
Although the satellite surface is streaked with a whole net of long and deep
cracks. Some of them may well reach as deep as the subsurface layer of water.
Thus the ice at the bottom of these ravines is valuable material for studying
the inner makeup of Europa.
Another peculiar feature of this moon is powerful ice cold vapor GIS.
They open up only when Europa is at its furthest point from Jupiter,
with the height of the spurts reaching as much as 200 kilometers.
These giant jets are made up of water vapor,
which incidentally is unexpected clean.
It is still not known for certain whether the Giza have anything to do with the
ocean in euros interior,
or they come from Garan churn lakes embedded in the satellites icy crust
today. The composition of the subsurface ocean on the satellite is estimated by
analyzing the ice covering in a part of its largest craters.
Only a really large object is capable of breaking the thick layer of the ice
clean through on impact.
After the icy crust is broken the water in the subsurface ocean at the impact
site freezes and forms the bottom of a crater spectral
analysis of the craters reveals magnesium sulfur and di compounds as well as
hydrogen peroxide and strong acids.
This demonstrates that there is a vast diversity of minerals in the satellites,
concealed hydrosphere, your ropes atmosphere contains oxygen,
which forms as a result of ultraviolet radiation,
interacting with the ice water on the surface,
splitting the water into oxygen and hydrogen, the satellite's atmosphere,
however, is approximately a trillion times as rare refined as that of our earth.
Still according to some estimates,
concentration of oxygen in Europa's subsurface ocean should be sufficient for
supporting single cell aerobic life forms under water.
Volcanoes should be their sources of energy and food.
As they saturate water with sulfur and dine oxides,
primitive organisms may attach themselves to the bottom side of the ice crust or
swim freely in water.
It was even assumed that there made dwell primitive multicellular organisms in
Euro ocean. However,
this hypothesis appears to be rather too presumptuous.
In fact, there is a great many species on our earth,
which would be able to survive in the estimated conditions of UX subsurface
ocean. There are among them not only bacteria resistant to harsh environments,
but multicellular creatures too. For example, tar degrades,
consequently,
we cannot rule out the possibility of primitive life originating in the depths
of this celestial object of its own accord.
Unfortunately enough in spite of the keen interest we have in Jupiter and
its satellites so far,
they've been investigated only briefly and that by spacecraft passing them on
our whale swear,
no landings on the gas giant satellites have so far been attempted at the
moment.
The largest planet in our system is being investigated by the Juno probe.
But as soon as in July, 2021, it will move on to studying the Galilean moons.
The data collected by Juno will undoubtedly be of great importance and help
get to the bottom of processes taking place in Jupiter's system.
As for upcoming missions. Back in 2012,
the European space agency are now starting work on the juice project or
Jupiter icy moon Explorer. The mission of the project is to explore in detail,
the gas giant itself,
as well as ADE Europa and Calisto juice will be launched next year,
but will reach Jupiter environs early in 2029.
The mission is scheduled until the year 2033.
All goes according to plan our knowledge about the gas giant added satellites
will be substantially expanded.
Another big research project is NASA's Europa clipper.
This automatic probe is planned to lift off the Earth's surface,
not later than 2023 and to reach Jupiter's system in
2032, the probe's objective is quite predictably Euro.
In contrast to Jew,
it is this celestial body that clipper is supposed to focus on more closely.
Admittedly, all the, these expeditions are plans for the future.
I have no doubt that new valuable and illuminating data will be collected as
a result, which we will do our best to process and make new informative videos.
Our knowledge about the universe grows by the day.
And Cosmo is happy to bring you up to speed.
If you found this video captivating and enough,
feel free to hit the like button and subscribe if you still haven't done.
So we would appreciate it.
If you shared the link with your friends who are also into space and let's keep
in touch,